Ah. So nervous.
One thousand.
Take one, baby.
Dirty pig. Go away.
We are not done.
Oh, my god. Sorry.
We were on a hill.
I'm so sorry.
Last week I didn't do a shit
for five days.
And when I finally
did do a poo,
it was like my bum had this
gigantic orgasm.
Oh, it was great.
It was like my bum had this
gigantic orgasm.
No, I got that part.
I got that bit.
I was trying to
compose myself.
-Constipation you say?
-Mmm.
How bad?
Well… It were almost
coming out of me mouth.
What was that Otis?
Perfect pork cheese boy.
Can you say I'm so nervous?
Can you give me
one little kiss guys?
-Me and Mimi?
-Yeah.
-On the lips?
Where the fuck else?
-Wait. Out of nowhere?
-Out of nowhere.
Just listening
to their conversation.
What kind of kiss?
-Just a little peck.
-Okay.
Just checking in.
-Just checking your throat.
Ready?
I watch the Kardashians
with my mum.
Well, well, well.
Sorry. Sorry.
Remi, I've had a lot
of casual sex.
Remi? You said it now.
You see what the problem is?
You see? I'm not Remi.
I'm not the motorcycle man.
Did you get a haircut?
What's a naked family?
Well, you know.
Naked family.
You know, families that walk
around naked,
everyone talks
about their feelings.
Like you and Mrs. Jean.
I bet you walk around
naked all the time.
Like you and Mrs. Jean.
I bet you walk around
naked all the time.
Fucking hell. I can't do it
if you're gonna laugh.
I bet you and your mum walk
around naked all the time.
Sorry. That's ridiculous.
I'm getting it.
Yeah, you're definitely
getting high.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Yeah. Or zooted as you say.
Who says that?
The British… I think.
Yeah, chopped.
-Chopped?
-Yeah.
When my mum died I was
so angry all the time and--
-I'm okay.
-Very good.
-I'm so angry all the time.
No, no, no. You know,
stay as long as you want,
but tomorrow is good.
-Oh, great.
-Or today, or whatever.
As long as I want?
-Yeah.
-Great.
Oh, suck it!
Don't worry, I douched
before school.
Where did it go?
It was here, I swear.
Maybe someone did it for a
hoax.
As a hoax.
Good luck.
Enough of the yearning
looks, you pillock.
Just tell her
you like her already.
It was at that point
Isaac knew
he shouldn't have
deleted that message.
I have more self-respect
than that.
Can you let me out, please?
Okay, it's actually locked.
Let me do that again.
Oh, fuck me. Sorry.
I think you've got nothing
to lose.
And if it all goes tits up…
I took too much flapjack.
One sec, lads.
You didn't shit
for five days?
Five.
-Yeah.
-Primal. Primal.
I was… I was holding myself
in the foetal position.
It was painful.
Action.
-Are you stalking me, woman?
What? No?
I have to slam
on the brakes first.
How did this happen?
Don't you know?
I'm not sure.
Oh, high five.
Oh yeah.
Fuck off!
Take 49.
…is my clitoris.
Drop.
What the fuck has happened
to your face?
Oh that was so good.
Woo!
You're right about the angry
eyebrows by the way.
You should see
her armpit hair.
It would be my honour
to put my dick in you.
I would love
It would be my honour
to put my dick in you.
Why is there
a camera crew here?
Do you know why, Goat?
Why did you do that?
I'm not gonna
disobey the rules
just because
you have a crush.
I haven't got a crush.
That's not the point.
Look, unlike you I'm taking
the role of head girl so--
Sorry. Sorry.
I made eggs.
Last time you made eggs
was when dad died.
He didn't die.
It's not about unity.
It's about control.
Well, you wouldn't be
wearing a nose ring
in a top law firm,
would you?
School's meant to prepare
you for the real world.
Sorry.
Later. Alright?
I'll go get a tissue.
Get a tissue.
Come in.
I don't know what I'm
doing. I'm really sorry.
Action.
So this one's labia's a bit
longer which is--
Look at all those tits.
I'm reorganising my men's…
vintage…
tit collection.
-I shed blood over what?
-Justice.
A rectangle man so
unremarkable--
Maeve Wiley's
not on the coach.
That can't be right.
I'm so sorry.
Maeve Wiley's
not on the coach.
Well,
good.
-This is the one.
-That was the plan.
He said "That's nice."
What?
Hold on.
Sorry. No. Sorry. Sorry.
Would you like some tea?
No.
-Nesquik?
-I don't want any Nesquik.
What's this?
Oh, it's a scheme thing.
Study in America
for a couple of months.
My teacher wants me to
apply. I don't know.
-That doesn't sound stupid.
-I didn't say it was.
Hang on.
You need to keep
to the left of the line.
Oh.
Okay. Cut. Reset.
I've got an appointment
with--
Reset please.
I've got you an appointment.
Hello, Mr. Hendricks.
Thank you.
Thank you, Adam Groff.
For owning up
to doing this huge poo
and undermining
my authority.
Cheers mate.
Thank you, mate.
Cheers.
Je suis. Je suis a l'aise.
Why are you laughing?
You dad has very good taste.
Those are my mum's actually.
She loved anything
with peonies.
And I love everything
with penises.
You must be Jackson
Marchetti, famed head boy.
Sorry.
You must be Jackson
Marchetti, famed head boy.
That would be me.
So sorry.
I'm so sorry Jemima.
Get Simion in there.
Simion, smile through it
okay?
And, Quentin you're not a
fucking tenor.
Shut up!
Alistair's acting now.
Set. Set. And action.
Apparently quieter school--
Wow. Wow.
Mum?
Back it up.
Would you believe I didn't
put my phone in my pocket?
Jakob.
And fish and chips.
Also I like peanut b--
Fuck.
Also I like peanut butter
on toast but not toast.
Fuck.
What the fuck was that?
I just saw a spider
the size of Gibraltar.
Are you ready for it VT?
It's a series wrap
for Asa B.
Series wrap
for Asa Butterfield.